[Music]
considering the huge amounts of football
that happened in the first two episodes
filling a 1 minute and 30 second recap
is actually quite impressive running
between a giant polar sloth legs without
consent creating your vanity intro only
include helmets or droids which means
you end up including an mse 6 repair
droid instead of a han solo this darth
vader gets dressed while obi-wan prays
to the cameo voices on high segment goes
on for all the some time wait i'm
confused everything we've seen before
shows the helmet and faceplate is two
distinct parts that need to be placed on
in order the faceplate hinges on the
mouthpiece and then the helmet seals it
all into the compression chamber and
don't give me any crap about them
changing to a new suit because they
would have had to change back by the
time luke removes it later at his death
this isn't a new coke situation it's a
continuity error
look edging is great or so i've been
told but there comes a point when heavy
breathing alone loses its impact and you
just need to release the red stick of
doom modeling your evil lair after
mordor middle earth
i have been watching you third sister
it's so great to have james earl jones
back for this hang on i need to adjust a
few things here
okay it's so great to have the digitally
recreated and disembodied voice
harnessed outside of its original owner
with no human performance and ruthlessly
mined to generate dollars for a soulless
corporation back for this
i'll be almost there kid asks an adult
are we there yet in a transportation
situation
the force cliche it or something
that's not how it works i mean it could
though right if i know one thing about
star wars the force can be used to do
the exact things the story needs it to
but then also won't do the exact things
the story needs it not to so really
obi-wan just use a jedi mind trick on
the writers and you should be good to go
have you ever been afraid of the dark
how does it feel when you turn on the
light i feel safe comparing the mystical
galactic weave that provides superpowers
to both good and evil to a nightlight
lola
she was a showdroid with red accents on
her flare and seven lives or so to spare
you hear that sound it's as if millions
of zippers simultaneously unzipped in
ecstasy because yet another star wars
spaceship takeoff or landing has been
shown in its mind-meltingly slow
entirety whew we traded the sand deserts
to tatooine for something completely
different a dusty desert what is this
place
mapuzo
it's a mining system writing dialogue
into your show for the sole purpose of
wikipedia look at all this headroom this
is a ton of wasted space why are there
so many stormtroopers just aimlessly
patrolling
aimlessly he could be anywhere i traced
the manifest oh you traced the manifest
did you cool so should i send this for
such a generic tactic explanation or
sent it for obi-wan being able to be
followed because of such a generic
tactic explanation and just throw a sin
on and let the comments fall where they
may and when the sea metronome is fully
mature it will spread its seed to the
other planets so that a new generation
of aquatic melodic timing devices can
populate the galaxy at least i assume
that's what's happening here considering
we're spending all this time on it you
don't talk
got it i feel rather frustratingly that
she will very quickly prove that she
doesn't in fact got it maybe they're
just late maybe it was a lie i knew it i
never should have trusted him we don't
know
no one is coming here leia man obi-wan
sure did turn into a condescending
cynical prick over the last 10 years
didn't he he reprimands leia's optimism
so quickly and forcefully here that he
might as well threaten her with a
timeout if she dared say anything else
even the slightest bit hopeful also as
shown at the end of the episode obi-wan
gives up way too quickly on this meeting
i mean it's not like they had a set time
of departure from space vegas or a set
arrival time on slightly greener
tatooine so how does anyone know when
the actual meeting time is supposed to
be and if it's a trap wouldn't they have
been caught as soon as they turned up
what are you doing
maybe they can give us a ride to the
spaceport
but it's not safe then stop her my
goodness man if you truly believe this
is too dangerous then stop letting the
10 year old make all the decisions
especially since what sounds like zack
braff doing a seth rogen impersonation
here does give them up to the
stormtroopers father aren't you going to
say hello
hello there come on you are dying for
him to say it too they're moving us
around
looking for a jedi i can't believe that
in the last 10 years obi-wan the most
famous living jedi doesn't have one of
the most recognizable phases in the
galaxy especially to stormtroopers
hunting a jedi what are you doing out
here
that's a long story
it's a long way the stormtrooper version
of a long way is apparently a one minute
and 15 second journey good to know they
know what they're doing there i can sort
of go with obi-wan has lost touch with
the force or obi-wan is getting older
and his skills are diminishing but i'm
not sure i can get on board with obi-wan
in a moment of crucial conversation when
he should be on high alert calls his
undercover daughter by her actual name
as if he's some third-rate criminal in
an episode of ncis remember your father
i wish i could say i was weird time to
tell leia regrets missing the
opportunity to bang her mom but okay
i remember a baby
a baby yes i think i had a brother
coming soon to a disney plus near you
ob2 kenobi a story so important you
won't believe how little you care about
star wars anymore a couple of strays i
found thought you might want to check
them out no
not frack betrayed by the only one
betrayed by someone so betrayed by
by
who was frank again initiate protocol 23
no not protocol 23 how will they stop
the
when the troopers do the
what will happen when when
what was protocol 23 again
[Applause]
holy [ __ ] that storm trooper just got
cut in half bisected stormtroopers the
new titanic propeller guy and i demand
merch also despite having the high
ground that obi-wan is so fond of this
stormtrooper won't join in on the fight
until all of his friends are dead
surely shooting the control panel only
works if the control panel is also the
power source for the barrier this is
like me smashing my keyboard and
expecting my pc to turn off also would
it have really been so hard to
walk around it out of the way he says to
the person who is no longer in the way
so the audience will know he's a dick
you know in case the fact that he's a
storm trooper didn't tip you off to that
possibility quick another adult is
kneeling to talk with leia emotional
conversation is incoming skip now it is
not wise to upset a cine droid
maintenance it's all automated no one
ever comes in here which means that when
anyone sees you go in there it's
probably suspicious no next time pick a
hideout where you won't be found out
just by walking through the front door
maybe he's just a loader they don't
allow them to communicate but what if he
has something to say
actions speak louder than words so that
would be communicating then quinlan was
here quinlan you say as if i'm supposed
to have watched every single star wars
thing and know that name and be very
excited which of course i have because
i'm totally as big of a star wars fan as
you are and i'm well aware of how that
one time when quinlan did that one thing
hey question why are the jedi writing
their names on the wall like some sort
of jedi database in case this room is
ever discovered what does it say
only when the eyes are closed
can you truly see that's actually only
the first line i've read this one on a
bathroom stall before the full poem is
only when the eyes are closed can you
truly see because that's when the sense
of smell comes to distinguish from pee
it really ruins the full impact when you
cut it short like that obi someone must
have seen us we're moving up the
timeline wait if that was always an
option why wasn't it always the plan i
can't imagine obi-wan kenobi doing
anything wrong showing a complete lack
of imagination ben
what is it he's sensing darth anakin
that's what because any time the story
needs it force users can sense another
important force user around them but
sometimes when it wouldn't make sense
they just completely miss it like for
instance when you're within a few feet
of your own force-sensitive daughter
just as one random example
dude vader just force-snapped a kid's
neck for defending his father i'm super
glad this whole saga is about the
redemption of this guy every move just
makes the end of episode 6 so much more
jubilant
[Music]
okay i'm only human let's do this oh
okay well i'm sure they're saving the
epic battle for the end of the episode i
just hope that it does end up being
episode 4 a new hope what have you
become
mostly a villainous trump card for
disney to pull out every time they need
to goose their ip interest in a bit if
we're being honest riva checks the exact
building she needs to check and we're
never told why other than the
inquisitive look she gave discount
bumblebee the years have made you weak
point until you see what the next 10
years does to him he'll almost look like
another person the thing is on wheels
riva there'll be plenty of opportunities
to show your powers you don't have to
force it now keep running till you reach
the port a pilot will meet you there she
leaves the 10 year old princess alone i
know vader's toying with an out of
practice obi-wan but i've seen more
captivating lightsaber battles at the
local swimming pool with foam water
noodles now you
will suffer
only one anakin and obi-wan set each
other on fire in episode three of a star
wars property cliche also obi-wan
survives this without needing a life
support suit or needing to be voiced by
james earl jones
[Music]
and despite darth literally just easily
putting the same fire out mere seconds
ago this will offer enough cover for the
several minutes obi-wan needs to be
saved are you the one i'm supposed to
meet no that's riva which makes no sense
considering she was on the other side of
those tunnels and leia's been clearly
shown to be the fastest sprinter in the
known galaxy and was running the entire
way also my favorite thing is that this
show is now basically the shampoo of
star wars shows just keeps wash rinse
repeating episode 1 leia kidnapped
episode 2 leia rescued episode 3 leia
kidnapped i hope it just goes on like
this for another 20 episodes so we
really hammer home the point that leia's
defining characteristic is just
continuously being in peril
oh will you shut up
one
for the dark lord on his dark throne in
the land of mordor
what's the matter
i have a headache it might be a tumor
it's not a tumor it's not a tumor at all
there were fields and families
old man peabody
on all of this
he had this crazy idea
about breeding pine trees
you
are not in charge here you're not the
boss of me yes i am
so long and thanks for all the fish this
is my father orton we're farmers from
tallahassee beholder
i am always beneath
[Music]
that's gonna leave a mark it wasn't your
fault lair
it's not your fault they don't allow
them to communicate
but what if he has something to say the
ability to speak does not make you
intelligent
see what
the way
this is the way